hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm also Greg Alba but really I'm John
Greg Alvin Greg Albert are gonna watch
together today the Greg Alva story
starring Mark Wahlberg and eco with mild
22 restricted trailer numero dos we know
that we have a lot of Indonesian
subscribers because one of the things
that helped grow this channel is when we
covered the raid so it shouts out to
Indonesia people whoo so we like the
first trailer I'm hoping this red band
trailer it can give us a little bit more
before we do that I want to give a shout
out to the most Indonesian guy from our
patron I could think of Gregory Bullock
Gregory Bullock is a man that I've been
talking with a lot and messages and I
know you're kind of going through a
rough patch right now buddy and I hate
to put you on the spot like that but
quit being a [ __ ] no [ __ ] I want to
say I talk with you because I really do
care you have such a kind-hearted soul
you are incredibly generous and you're
also one of the most observational
people I have ever known
you are the best at deconstructing what
John and I do and how our personalities
function we've had people analyze us
before and we're kind of used to that
but when you talk to me I'm like this
guy really gets what we do might not
seem like a lot but when you get a guy
like Gregory both to deconstruct you
you're like yeah you know we're pretty
cool you should sit on the road do some
observational stand-up but all about it
yeah I hope that you stay vigilant and
watchful because I know the meaning of
your name I looked it up 20 years ago
keep at the music ends you have some
awesome tunes man awesome tunes there's
more tea
[Music]
[Music]
this is an overwatch operation prepare
our vision is to complete the mission at
any cost
we get week on the beach you're never
gonna do something wrong until you die
that's what this job is I'm not you
you're pretty close
besides this is my Beach feel the sand
between my toes you ever walk in acid da
miss rex medically says he is
what is the name leader are you involved
in accidents Bernard yes I have
information that proof my government is
planning an attack
[Music]
[Music]
no one ever does war think they will
lose one side is always wrong
[Music]
[Music]
we're save millions of lives
requesting hand of God coming down hand
of God
[Music]
yeah Equal Rights if you're gonna kill a
bunch man you gotta kill at least one
woman yeah that balance is everything
this a man you put Eko except for Star
Wars The Force awakens you put equalize
that mean anything and I want to see it
yeah looks like he just brings with him
and level bone-crunching action
ingenuity that just blows my mind he's
yeah man I hope the camera doesn't cut a
lot on the hand-to-hand combat if he
doesn't go full green grass when it
comes like the chaotic shootouts and
stuff I usually have a lot less problems
with something like that get it they can
see me yeah it's a chaotic situation
assault rifles and stuff but for the
hand-to-hand so specially cuz you got
eco wise I want to make sure you can see
everything's going on it looks like for
the most part you can there do the
marking on this pretty smart actually
this is one of those things where they
are actually really advertising him in
the movie this could easily have been
something where like this is bigoted but
Mark Wahlberg yeah lauren cohan it's the
white kid yeah they're being really
smart about this and even though it's an
american film they're pretty much making
him the main appeal of it he's the
intrigue of the movie yeah this is
telling me it's a plot and action he's
the main entry because it looks like
he's gonna drive a lot of this movie
anyway and bring a lot of the punch -
yeah I do like when they bring over
famous martial arts international stars
to the States sometimes you can be a
little iffy about that sometimes you get
a little open for which was alright but
that doesn't really showcase jelly's
charisma and sometimes you get a Donnie
Yen in Shanghai it's like alright as a
cameo in force awakens yeah this is the
right kind of role he's a different kind
of action star as opposed to Jet Li or
Jackie Chan or even a Donnie Yen the
rate films I made him so popular are a
lot more gritty they're a lot more
grungy and in your face like a lot of oh
you know when you watch those fights so
you want to put him in a movie that will
allow him to do that kind of action
sequences this looks like a good step
for it well it looks like a good blend
of different styles of action you look
like you're probably gonna get a lot of
car chases a lot of you know
shootouts along with the elevated
hand-to-hand combat element you know
this sure made it pretty clear and it's
cool text of the 90 minutes you got a
good ticking time clock here whenever
you have a good clock that can make for
a really good action tension yeah really
good tension hand looks like Mark
Wahlberg will get the gun action lauren
cohan will get a mixture of both evil
why yeah she just slam through the wall
at one point so it looks like even the
you know famous pretty white actors are
doing this movie for her especially I'm
always fascinated when actors make the
big tree I know she's done movies before
but you know make the transition from
being known for TV into motion pictures
like this and at least by the look of it
I feel like she might actually kill it
in this movie like this might actually
open things up for her in that front
this is feeling more like an in samba
movie unless like a Mark Wahlberg movie
you know like a Mark Wahlberg Peter Berg
collab yeah me see John Malkovich in his
trailer was weird ass looking here at
them which is a weirdo it looks like
it's gonna play a very normal character
you have Ronda Rousey who's not in these
trailers at all but her name keeps being
slapped on her yeah you know we'll see I
don't know why that is actually I feel
like you would want to showcase her I
feel like what they're leading with a
hundred percent is action and intensity
so maybe they randomly cast her for a
desk roller so I'm just saying if you if
you show us too much in the trailer I
hate it cuz it spoils the movie if you
don't show us enough I hate it cuz I
want to know more to your job Depp it up
to find the balance and make me happy
make it perfect you got to have
perfection in your market team for her
because you're only showing the same
shots from four different action scenes
any Peter Berg tends to go from like
gritty dramas to action movies it mixes
it up between us I want to specifically
bring up the kingdom because the last
half hour is a super intense
gritty handheld action sequence it's a
really intense finale this kind of feels
like a 90-minute version of that yeah
this is a cool trailer if you guys
excited for at Mile 22 you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell cuz hey subscribe
buttons are broken these days you can
check us out at patreon we got a
full-length TV
reaction weekly Q&A s music video
coverage love to have you become a
patronage act today